admirer la tour eiffel la cité de
carcassonne ou encore le château de
chambord en quelques heures seulement
c'est de nouveau possible chez france
miniature les 117 monument répartis sur
le parc situé à elancourt se sont tous
refait une beauté durant l'hiver il faut
refaire les peintures refaire toutes les
scénographies et puis on a cinq hectares
de terrain sur france miniature donc
c'est un parc paysager
donc il ya un gros travail pour moi
période de leader en plus des monuments
des expériences interactives et des
attractions quelques nouveautés pour
cette saison un livret jeu pour le jeune
public mais aussi la voix de stéphane
bern qui résonnera dans le parc
un choix qui s'est imposé de lui même il
ne cherche à travers ces émissions à
vulgariser le patrimoine français et
c'est exactement aussi la vocation de
france miniature
donc on va retrouver des commentaires
sur albi sur le beffroi l'hôtel de ville
de douai on va retrouver sur versailles
évidemment tous les grands monuments que
nos visiteurs attendent en fait sont
sonorisés maintenant avec ces qr code et
ce guide de luxe un voyage insolite aux
quatre coins de france qui séduit aussi
bien les grands que les petits voir tout
ce qui peut tout ce qu'on peut faire en
france qu'on sait pas forcément comme ça
on n'a pas forcément idées et là ça
donne aussi des idées de voyage ou ou se
balader en france c'est vrai que ça
c'est sympa on peut voir shakarchi
architecture avec tous les détails comme
cité la vraie une réouverture qui est
tombée cette année pendant les fêtes de
pâques
à cette occasion une chasse aux oeufs
étaient organisés qui cite les 3 4
6 et rien de mieux qu'une notes
chocolatées pour lancer cette nouvelle
saison